les deux hommes ont parlé de la
coopération entre leurs deux pays et la
Turquie et la Russie de la médiation
turque et beaucoup de gaz il y a une
petite déclaration conjointe à la presse
après l'entretien et Vladimir Poutine a
surtout parlé de gaz il a dit que
aujourd'hui la Turquie était la route la
plus fiable pour transporter du gaz
russe vers l'Union européenne et il le
proposait donc c'était déjà une
proposition qu'il avait fait avant cette
rencontre il est revenu dessus la
construction d'un grand centre de
distribution de gaz en Turquie aux
portes de l'Union européenne il a
indiqué à son interlocuteur regga hyper
douanes que les prix étaient très hauts
et que la construction et l'existence
d'un tel centre permettrait de fixer des
prix je cite sans connotation politique
d'autres responsables russes avaient
déjà parlé de cette possibilité certains
ont évoqué la possibilité de rajouter
des lignes au gazoduc turc Stream qui
passe sous la mer Noire et le ministère
Turcs de l'énergie avait déjà réagi hier
en expliquant que un tel projet était
réalisable donc du côté russe on a
surtout parlé d'énergie côté turc
réceptable perdwan est revenu sur la
médiation de son pays en ce qui concerne
le corridor maritime pour acheminer le
grain à travers la mer Noire via
Istanbul et les détroits Turcs il a dit
que c'était très important pour lui de
s'assurer que tout ces céréales soient
acheminées soit transporté vers les pays
qui ont le plus besoin vers les pays les
moins développés et qu'il était un peu
inquiet de voir que la plupart de ces
céréales était en direction de pays plus
développés il s'est félicité de la bonne
relation et de la bonne coopération ce
qui concerne l'énergie en ce qui
concerne le commerce entre son pays et
la Russie là par exemple évoqué la
construction la première réacteur qui
serait mis en service dans la centrale
nucléaire d'akuyu construit par le russe
rosatum en Turquie elle aurait de
l'année prochaine c'est-à-dire la
quatrième fois en trois mois que les
deux présidents se rencont contre et on
ne compte plus le nombre de fois où ils
se sont eu au téléphone c'est une
relation qui est très importante pour
les deux même si la Turquie est membre
de l'OTAN elle ne participe pas aux
sanctions contre la Russie on voit que
c'est une relation qui compte pour les
deux hommes et qui fonctionne